[Music]
these people created a website that is a
fake Amazon dating website where they
literally make it look like Amazon but
they put people up for sale wow that
sounds really fun
so yes it's open slave trading yeah but
they don't look like hookers though so
you know when this they look like
American Apparel does it like yeah this
social climate we have today I don't
know who's for jokes right so for sure
its jokes but you know how people hey
dude if this was in Libya right now
wouldn't be a joke that shit's back oh
no I don't know yeah you know what
happened slave markets in Libya thanks
to us we destroyed a literate country
that had education and health care and
we [ __ ] up that little African nation
our foreign policies pre kick ass
sometimes yeah I know right so it's not
a real dating website or it is it's not
so it's so this looks like and then up
here it says like your last relationship
is one of the options you can click on
and when you click on that it takes you
to a YouTube music video of Brittany's
song toxic what's the joke of it though
your last relationship is toxic that's
the yeah I think it would have been
funnier if this dating site was a bunch
of athletic women why is that funny
Amazon baby no Amazon women because
they're less desirable whoa I'm sorry I
thought he was gonna say okay but I
think that you're right I stand by that
I said then it turns out no one thought
that exactly okay that's even better
then we can't feel good so some people
don't like this yeah no I mean it's just
it went viral so look what the [ __ ] is
that
that's teddy this teddy he's 87 Jesus
Teddy could get it
he's the Amazon deal of the day and so
down here it has like the what is it
love language so his love language is a
word
affirmation it's not physical you could
even hear it you look good today huh
what would what under deal of the day it
says might expire soon though that's
messed up that's pretty good like words
where it's not there that's not as my
joke it what it feels that easy you
could just buy the person you want and
you could pick the height because in
this drop-down menu thing you know I
don't like that you can pick that
discriminatory no I kind of like that
what if you are able to be the height
that they want you that'd be tight no
like if there was some sort of like
thing fantastical world we're gonna get
different universe there was some crazy
girl that wanted 5/4 card can make you
big don't like it so patronizing I love
it not cool not cool tip she was trying
to hype you up she was trying to you're
like what if I'm not upset at all
securing myself anyway moving on so then
once you select your options here when
you're trying to check out when you pick
someone whole team checked out now they
give you like your delivery option could
be today by 5:00 p.m. or whatever it is
and you can actually do this on their
site because I pick someone and I did
Add to Cart and I put place your order
and then it sends you here because they
don't collect actual credit card
information because obviously they can't
you say you picked him no no the article
is this something that Amazon did fake
the Amazon dating thing that someone is
made for for the laws for the law and
it's not pushing towards any like
website or not okay it's just the
creative art exactly is just I get it
these content creators named Susie Shin
any of copán
Morgan grew Neil collaborated ger grew
they collaborated with an animation
company named think oh and they created
this satirical service Amazon dating
site it's funny because Amazon owns
everything so if they have a dating
service - I wouldn't be surprised right
you get everything there you get your
whole life and you can get laid you know
that you're a [ __ ] old man now when
you order hangers off Amazon and your
decide to do yeah
because like I usually I'll go get them
and online have to be a specific type of
hanger not just any the word the wooden
of the call but then ones the velvet one
sneaky three times the sole thin yeah
they're called something they're called
something yeah Nikki would I know that
she knows what it's called to and it was
impressive not just thin hangers did not
mean they are faking here's what it's
even deeper than that there's something
I don't even know how I had hangers back
in a day that's a good point when did
they come where do they come from great
you were just there I mean you just
stole your parents - yeah the metal ones
there's all different colors and stuff -
and then there's still the advertisement
from the dry cleaners my parents would
have like a lot of clothes in their
[ __ ] small closets I would if I
needed a hanger I would take it out but
it was so sandwich every just to leave
the clothes take up the hanger whoever
invented the hanger where you can spin
it while it's still hung up this is
[ __ ] genius
oh yeah just has a little thing attached
to the thing and you can spin it yeah
yes cuz sometimes I need to turn around
and I don't want to take it off the
thing goes as heavy or whatever and I
can just spin it - I'm like that person
thank you why you want to turn it around
to that inventor so so they're all the
same we're all facing the same direction
yeah exactly thank you for Kant worried
guys have you seen those hanger thingies
the attachments to your hanger so
there's like a hook so there's two hooks
that goes like this and then there's
like sections divided for you to put
each individual hanger and then you let
go one hook and then it's like that's
Clanton so it's safe space in your
closet but I hate it so if you guys want
it you can have it
wait why do you hate it it sounds stupid
I hate it because when I'm trying to get
a piece of clothing from it like I need
a rehang in and then grab it and then do
it
well that does too much yes that's dumb
you know what I miss about metal hangers
though I made the biggest [ __ ]
bubbles with that [ __ ] I get dishwashing
Oh smart I had the [ __ ] big-ass like
turkey tray I squeeze that [ __ ]
in there put water and I'll be in my
backyard get the hangar and then I'll
deconstruct that yeah yeah and then I
just big guys bought this baby was
anyone else there we're just doing this
for yourself
now's me look not gonna lie to this day
every once in a while as a grown-ass man
I'll buy the [ __ ] biggest bubble
thing I'll just be like just blow that
[ __ ] we played with one that had like a
like a rope attached to these two
strings and then like you're supposed to
do this thingy and then you were like
get ya [ __ ] gigantic the best time you
guys ever get the big plastic bubbles
that you can't pop no never got em
either
I saw him on TV but I was always like oh
I that's too expensive
my mom was like you can't get that [ __ ]
it's like a gassy smell to it
hi what is this dude who's a bubble that
can't it doesn't pop whoa I don't know
if it's the same thing you're talking
about but the one that I knew of it's
like a super tiny little metal
toothpaste that's what I know
looking thing and it had like a little
straw you're probably right yeah had
like a few minutes [ __ ] like a huge
bubble drink you know none huge yeah no
were you talking about
that's a gag [ __ ] man and the commercial
they made to do the most gigantic
bubbles no like you can't pop and I
always wondered if anyone ever got I'm a
googly Amazon I ordered on Amazon
everything dude yeah I don't even go to
the store anymore my new [ __ ] at 3 a.m.
is to him it's like I'll think of stuff
from my childhood and Google to see if
there's a t-shirt for it now order an
Amazon cuz you think of random shaking
me up at 3 a.m. like answering emails
like a goonie shirt yeah we're like boys
wilt like random seem like oh man no
doubt tragic kingdom' not really good
album and you see if there's a t-shirt
we just bought one or I'll be like oh
man
xpac WWE he was cool and she does xpac
t-shirt and I've just been ordering
random t-shirts Garbage Pail Kids male
kids oh my god sue nah dude oh ok ok
yeah
Russell's back him and or him Burmese
animal yeah yeah he used to do the [ __ ]
where he's like yeah and that was like
part of this [ __ ] finishing move yeah
he was the really sad on them or the one
used to rub his ass and people's faces
I'm washy key or something yeah yeah
good times we old anyway we're talking
about Amazon dating remember these dudes
oh yeah the bushwhackers Hilaire so
funny I recently did I wonder if at the
t-shirt I did a dating show last night
oh yeah how is that you yeah it was
funny yeah I it's on that East meets
eats that was a bit real like I what
happened what is it I like this they had
a new format of a dating show on the app
you can go live it's kind of like like
live streaming and if people could give
you gifts and [ __ ] like that right so
boom there's a host who hosted it right
right
I don't know it was last name he's
[ __ ] supposed to pay me to do
that [ __ ] they never played my email
filigree downs like eBay me and they
never black if I wanted you to do for
free I don't know I go on well yeah he
well he actually invented this format so
he was the host yeah and I come in and
then like I I choose like there's like a
list of girls that want to get beamed in
and then I just choose ya then when they
get beamed in like like they just ask
questions and it was like see them yeah
there's like a it's like a like a live
stream like like just saying yet any
girls went yeah was yeah was anyone cute
you went on a date with someone no no I
mean like they win a chance to go on a
day but like literally like the girl
that won she's from Kansas and [ __ ] but
no it was funny those there was those up
to last two contestants right and there
were so [ __ ] hilarious and wild they
suggested that they both tag-team me and
we go on a triple day and we have a
threesome are you doing looking awesome
but no she's in Kansas and so no yeah
no does that mean right that's what I'm
saying do it yeah okay
you just get a fight
like you know they were hilarious and I
think it was really it was like a fun
event because you know each Macy's is
kind of conservative right it's kind of
it's not really a it's not it's not only
fans you know I mean it's not it's not a
it's not a camera sight you know to me
but we [ __ ] turned it into a certain
thing they gave me a list of lame ask
questions and I'm all like I'm gonna say
these questions all right I was like
yeah I was like I was like this is what
I'm gonna say I [ __ ] this though so
there's this one segment in the final
round which just mean the two girls cuz
you could only beam in two people at a
time okay so the host was like okay I'm
gonna leave now here's the questions
you're supposed to ask him and I was I
was about to ask her when I got you know
what [ __ ] this I have another I have
another question okay you two girls
alright so you wake up to me naked next
to you you don't know what the hell
happened but you just wake up in the
morning what would you do
you know like there'll be a perfect
answer yeah cuz I want to see how they
would react if they're down to earth if
they're funny about it what would they
do look are they funny about being about
being drugged we worked up to this level
of comedy together it wasn't out of
nowhere like hey girl what would you do
if you woke up with me with my dick in
your mouth like it wasn't that crazy
right it was like we worked up to this
level of comfort and humor together yeah
but at this point I said this and then
one of them's like I'll probably cook
for you Oh like that's a [ __ ] dope
ass answer and you still don't want to
fly to Kansas and the other one said
what Kansas so far apparently wait what
do the other ones they you doesn't
remember this forgettable
I forgot listen you're talking to
married men right now we're trying to
[ __ ] squeeze slide them out and pay
for the date that that would be such a
dope episode right so fly them out um
the other ones in New York do all the
ones in canidates Kansas and I was like
let's have a triple date yeah it'll be
really fun
yeah yeah have them do that haven't pay
for it don't know fun event perfect
promo for them did you open the thing
being like hey if you're not into games
giving rim jobs is getting the [ __ ] out
of here
eat ass yes or no no Oh bleep and did
you see no but so there was one round
where I was allowed to ask a question
and they're allowed to ask me a question
and I was just having fun with this and
then I asked one of the girls I was like
so do you do one-night stands
that was the first question and they
[ __ ] laugh and they're like yeah I've
done that before and I'm like she's cool
yeah yeah
and then she gets off and she's like I
think I just got off the phone with my
neck my future husband he's me East
sponsored a [ __ ] or your dumb that would
be funny yeah
[Music]
[Music]